while many of us are stuck at home what
one thing is keeping a lot of people
busier than ever social media for some
people it's been a way to keep in touch
with friends and family for others it's
an outlet if you haven't been impressed
with the creativity coming out of
self-isolation
well as they say you haven't been
watching our Mike Armstrong has now
we've all had phones with cameras up
there at the top for a while now and
somehow we still film vertically but
there's something we haven't had until
now and that's a ton of time on our
hands
I have a friend for example sharing
pictures of his different sneakers it's
a little strange but that same friend
flagged this family having fun I'm not
sure how much skill went into making
this video but it's basically impossible
to watch without smiling
smiles are kind of the one infectious
thing that's okay right now
[Music]
now that video is one of thousands on a
Facebook page called
ultimate online Nova Scotia kitchen
party covered 19 edition
[Music]
the group started just two weeks ago and
is ballooned up to include contributions
from every corner of Canada and close to
a hundred other countries
well welcome from sunny South Korea the
organizer says there are a lot of people
looking to avoid cabin fever or as she
calls it Shack wacky I kind of like it
we have many different types of talent
we've got people who are literally just
picking up instruments for the first
time people who are dusting off their
old instruments and we've even got some
professionals in the group which is
pretty cool to see there are a lot of
parodies out there right now Disney's a
big inspiration hard to believe this
isn't the original
the hero fear is how it be from snakes
and bats bTW there are some new takes on
some old classics and there is no way I
was leaving the Barenaked Ladies out of
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now some have taken the inspiration of
this infection and created the sort of
music that gets into your head and
refuses to leave
[Music]
if it's a Canadian toe-tapper year after
they're out there I'll put the Prime
Minister on wearing masks prevent you
from speaking
[Music]
and I don't know if banjos and auto-tune
have ever been used together before but
it works for Alberta's premier talking
about hoarders there must be a special
place in hell a special race in hell
a special place in town a blank that
sticking with Alberta the orchestras in
Calgary and Edmonton set aside their
hockey rivalry and recorded on their
phones a very familiar tune
unfortunately it really makes me miss
hockey some of us don't find it quite as
easy as this Ontario family to occupy
our time they recreated the entire
Simpsons opening maybe skill is an
absolutely essential when it comes to
spreading smiles it helps if you can
hold a tune or know a specific dance but
you can be contagious in a positive way
[Music]
just by being positive
[Music]